Diane Von Furstenburg has helped shape
women's fashion for more than four
decades now for decades the iconic
designer is known for creating the wrap
dress in the 1970s Nora's got the 2019
version on today it's still going strong
it's a reissue as she says she empowers
women through both her designs and
philanthropy this year marks the 10th
anniversary of the DVF Awards the annual
ceremony will be held this week it
honors trailblazing women who use their
influence and the resources to transform
the lives of other women Dion joins us
at the table welcome back who are you
wearing today we're all wearing and I am
too I'm wearing DVF yes it's a classic
but this is what's so interesting ten
years and going strong congratulations
to you and ten but I read Dion that you
said when you first did it ten years ago
you were reluctant to put your name on
it because you didn't think it had the
prestige or the gravitas to put your
name on them well my son said well you
know you do so much for women and we
should use our foundation yeah to do an
award so when we can give money and you
can give exposure but it's very
intimidating to just out of the blue say
okay I'm creating an award with my name
yeah so you know and so I took advantage
of the beginning of the women in the
world conference that I started the year
either you know I was invited to start
with with Tina and so I thought okay we
will do that on the second night so I
can then with Tina Brown let's talk
about the Lifetime Achievement Award
this year is going to Anita Hill yes
yeah why Anita Anita is you know such a
tremendous I mean she's such a role
model I mean her courage her courage how
she could look at those men in the eyes
you know and just mention the world
penis and the world and and and not I
mean she is remarkable not sort of
presented by Gloria Steinem who sent it
back you know like that and so they're
both very happy about doing that
together and some it's an honor to have
those two women at the same time they
really are a role model because the
mission of the award is
to honor extraordinary women who have
the strength to fight the courage to
survive and the leadership to to inspire
John as somebody who had to fight
through that herself to be successful
how has in the ten years since the award
has been around how do you think it's
changed for women in America oh you know
we go on the pendulum I am part of the
generation that I'm a FEMINIST you know
I I grew up with Gloria Steinem so I'm a
FEMINIST with as many AM as possible
then I guess that my daughter's
generation they kind of took it for
granted but now that I see my
granddaughter's they are badasses
they're not gonna take anything so I
think this is a good time but I think we
cannot let it go by we have to seize it
because the 21st century is the century
for women if we want to save the world
yeah you know you talk about your
granddaughters and I think we should
talk about the me to movement for a
second because I think it's been very
good and very helpful but I also think
or do you think that there needs to be
room for redemption and reconciliation
for these men well that's my husband
says that we should have one solution
where all men say we admit and then
start over which is a totally fine idea
it's just like of course there's always
collateral damage of course there are
people who exaggerate but the truth is
that we can no longer be treated like
meat and people and men sometimes think
that they think it's a compliment that
they behaves like that and so I am I am
all me too there are so many truths that
you speak beyond which is the most
important relationship you have is with
yourself so first here what you're known
for you've also said you think of aging
as an acquisition not a loss I love that
how do you suggest that women embrace
getting older well first of all I'm 72
okay and proud to say it born on New
Year's Eve or not
truth is I live so fully I should be
twice my age and the point is that age
means that you exist it means you have
lived it so to hide your age means that
you're hiding part of who you are I mean
yes you know you don't have the same
assets you have a 20 but you have a lot
more assets of a lot of other things
nothing got to go but we Syrians and
wisdom we should mages power
we should mention Katy Perry you're
honoring Nadia Mirada course the Nobel
Peace Prize winner as well as others
that's later this week thing thank you
so much for having me yes did we mention
it's the tenth anniversary you're doing
something right
we'll be right back